hello folks welcome to rational science
directly from frankfurt germany
it's nine o'clock over here nine o'clock
at night whatever time it is at your
place
anyways today we're going to be talking
a little bit about
knowledge
and even before that we're gonna talk uh
we're gonna tie some loose ends from
last week we talked about philosophy
and there were some questions about that
so i want to cross some fees and dot
some eyes or vice versa maybe dot the uh
t's and cross the eyes
and uh we also have a
couple of flat earthers who raised
questions they wanted to know how um
how we curve water
especially without a container
and usually they don't wait for an
answer they never investigate they never
come back for an answer but this time
one of them did
and he had some perfect questions so
we're going to address that as well at
the end of the show
uh anyways let's begin with our
science critic he made a video
a 45-minute video criticizing the
scientific method
and he's entitled to do that the
question is whether he can defend his
his posture
today he talked about in in what we're
going to be analyzing today he talked
about time and gps and whether any of
that confirms
you know it's first whether it's been
verified and confirmed and second
whether that has
anything to do with physics
aside from the fact that you know the he
might
argue that it confirms general
relativity and again does that have
anything to do with physics so let's
move on with our science critic
and this is what he said
this is these are the issues okay and
let me set that up for you here here
goes listen carefully
the questions to be addressed in this
rebuttal are
can it be said in physics that time
flows
and
does it make sense in physics to say
that a mathematical concept such as time
is dilated
but the rest of those things all make
sense to me like time dilation for
example it's a change in the flow of
time depending on how fast you're going
or if you're in a gravitational well or
something like that and the thing is
time dilation has been measured it's why
gps needs to account for it
okay
so uh the issue is first whether time
flows
can we can we say in physics that time
flows
and does it make any sense to say that
um
time dilates in physics right we're
talking about physics here
and then finally uh you know uh just
another issue is whether gps
confirms that time dilates
and meaning that general relativity is
more or less correct
uh or perfectly correct and whether that
has anything to do with physics
so uh what i want to do is begin with mr
brian greene and he's going to help us
make our case today okay so this is what
brian green said in one of his
documentaries
hollywood movies really okay and here it
is this is the first one
and uh he saw
time
first uh under newton's eyes and as a
flowing river
and then uh he mentions that you know
when einstein came around he turned that
into a frozen river and that means that
you could now
more or less
imagine yourself walking towards the
future
on this frozen river okay this frozen
lake
okay um
then um from there he moved on to this
which is the
uh block universe he treated time
as a solid thing meaning that um you
know
we know the future or the future has
already happened
and essentially what you're doing is
walking in the footsteps
of what the programmer the designer the
uh what is it the um the the uh author
uh
designed for you it's like you know a
cartoon character you cannot deviate
from like bugs bunny you know bugs
cannot work outside the uh
script that was meant already done for
him and it's more or less what uh
what the the
uh relatives are saying they're saying
that your future's already been
determined all you're doing is walking
on footsteps
that are already there and that you
cannot avoid
it's like the movie's already been done
and you're just a little cartoon
character in that movie
that's their notion when they talk about
the block universe the question you know
a lot of people raise is what does that
do to free will you know means that we
don't have free will because someone
already designed our future and we're
just
going through the motions
that's more or less the notion we have
here okay um and from there you know
they get to this uh thing where they
turn time
into
uh not a frozen river because again they
go back to the flow
and because they want to show you that
gravity
is a warpage of what space
time
space time form this grid this canvas
this trampoline
and our waves along this uh this medium
so they turn it into a medium this time
thingy
and they want to explain with that why
or how what would happen if the sun were
to disappear
well they say you know gravity would not
disappear automatically because it would
take
time
for the gravity waves along space
time
to reach all the way to earth
that's the distance in light uh seconds
that we are from from the sun we're
eight minutes
in eight light minutes away from the sun
okay so if the sun were to disappear god
waves his magic wand makes the sun
disappear
the earth would not instantaneously fly
away it would take some time for those
gravity waves to reach the earth and
then the earth would not have any
gravitational influence would
gradually or maybe instantaneously air
drift away and this is how they picture
it imagine you know they do want to
illustrate it for you so that you can
imagine it so that you can visualize
what they are saying okay here it is
okay so if the sun disappears the
gravitational disturbance that results
will form a wave that travels across
right
uh the spatial fabric so they turn time
into this fabric in much the same way
that a pebble dropped into a pond makes
ripples that travel across the surface
of the water there you see the earth
running away from the solar system
simply because it has no gravitational
influence because the sun has
disappeared the sun is not weighing down
okay the canvas anymore and those waves
take eight minutes to reach us along
what a long space time
in other words what you have to
understand from this is that
they've turned time into a physical
object they're saying it's a medium of
some kind okay
that's essentially what they're saying
and the question is does that make any
sense in physics to say that time is a
physical object that flows and that can
be dilated
okay so
this is where we're having a problem
okay with the physical interpretation
and uh so here is
a uh a rundown of those two notions
is this time dilation what the
definition says which is the difference
in the elapsed time is measured by two
clocks
or is it the physical interpretation
meaning why the earth doesn't leave the
solar system which of these notions is
the real time dilation
and what they've done they merged these
two when you ask them what is time
dilation or you say why does the earth
fly out of the solar system they use the
one on the bottom they say well the
earth doesn't fly out of the solar
system because time is warped
okay time is warped and you say well
that's irrational
uh
you know and they bring all this time
dilation stuff all that thing and you
say well what do you mean by all that
well you know you're not supposed to
take the analogy so literally what we
really mean is the difference in elapsed
time as measured by two clocks well
these are two different notions of time
dilation one is used as a definition
saying we take two measurements and
they're different and the other one says
that you know time prevents the earth
from flying out of the solar system
okay so we have two these two notions
okay
and uh so yeah
unless we can reconcile them somehow
uh all they're doing is covering all
bases they're saying time is both things
both a physical interpretation because
it's a physical object that prevents the
earth from flying out and it's also you
know a measurement of some kind
and so
it's like they're covering both bases
one of them is irrational because it's
to say that time is warped
and so they say well you know you're
just taking the analogy too literally
no the issue is that we need to explain
why what causes what prevents right the
earth from flying out of the solar
system you have to explain that
and when they say time is warped is the
explanation
uh well that's not a physical
interpretation because time is not a
physical entity
and so the notion that general
relativity has out there
is poppycock it's nonsense uh you can't
sink your teeth into that now if they
want to use it as you know a measurement
of two measurements or whatever
comparison of measurements that's
irrelevant to to physics to science we
want to know why the earth doesn't fly
out of the solar system and they haven't
answered that question general
relativity does not have a theory
an explanation
general relativity has a description a
mathematical description and nothing but
okay
and regarding gps well here you have uh
the notion of gps okay
and uh it's uh
they'll tell you that gps works what
because you know they give you a cause a
mechanism time dilates
well
i don't know about that and he says it
has been measured and verified
okay
and so the question is does gps prove
that time is a physical object does gps
prove that time can be warped dilated
kicked around etc
i mean uh what are we talking about are
we talking about uh a
a measurement are we talking about the
fact that you know time can be
manipulated physically
and uh they give you an analog or they
use these other uh notions or arguments
against you they say your computer
wouldn't work if quantum were wrong
you know just like gps would not work if
general relativity were wrong these are
the types of
issues that they raise against you and
so again does the fact that your
computer works prove that a particle can
be a two places at once that's the
question because that's the theory
that's the explanation they give you and
the same thing with gps they're saying
you know the reason gps works is time
dilates what do you mean by that are you
saying that time is a physical object
that can be bent stretched or whatever
time dilates they use a physical term to
refer to time and they say well you
didn't understand what time dilates
means and they go back to the definition
rather than to the physical
interpretation they just finished giving
you and this is where we have a problem
okay
so uh yeah um
yeah we have a problem with uh with this
fella's conclusion
uh he just takes it at face value i
guess on the basis of authority and says
yeah it's been proven that gps works
the fact that gps works that's
technology has nothing to do with
science science is about explaining
not about developing gadgets and the
fact that gps works by trial and error
they figured out you know in fact they
did a jeep
gravity probe uh one and a and gravity
probe b
where they finally decided where they
were going to put the satellites they
determined all that you know by trial
and error they said you know they took
this thing and measured at different
steps what the time dilation was what
the time difference was and they got a
value and they say okay all we have to
do is put it here and we'll know how
much difference there should be at that
level
you know that's technology it's got
nothing to do with the explanation you
have to tell me why what caused
each clock
to travel or to to
tick at the rate that it does you know
these atomic clocks what makes them tick
at this speed up there and down here at
a different speed what came in contact
with the inside of the clock that's what
you got to explain but to say that it
does that's just a description you
haven't explained anything so you still
don't understand why what causes that to
happen all you know is that it does
and it does does not count as science
it's the cause
that
identifying to cause the mechanism is
what is identified as science as physics
okay all these people are doing is stamp
collecting
and someone asked me along the same
lines okay
uh about an interview i had a little
over a week ago
says you mentioned an interview last
episode care to link it are we gonna
hear about that one day
well uh i don't think you'll ever hear
about it because i haven't heard about
it okay just as simple as that what
happened was this fellow interviewed me
and um he thought
i essentially was going to come and
confirm his version of science okay
that's essentially what what it amounted
to
and you know when you interview someone
you believe you know you you think that
they're gonna listen to the guy that's
gonna
propose
his version of how he sees the world
that's not exactly what happened here we
started out more or less like that but
that's not how it ended in fact it ended
quite uh terribly
and that's why he did not upload the
video that's why i don't have a copy of
it he didn't even talk to me anymore
yeah i think he was upset okay and
here's a rundown so that you know what
happened on that day that's all i can
give you because there is no video okay
that you that i can point to or anything
like that
okay uh essentially he was trying to
indoctrinate me instead of interview me
okay he thought i thought like him
and so he was just kind of reinforce
uh what he already believed which also
happened in other
interviews with me okay people think
that i think like they do and they find
out that i don't
and uh so i told them up front what
science what science was to me that i
was proposing a new version of science
new version of the scientific method
that uh did away with everything we've
done in the last three thousand years
and greeks included okay all of it is
washed aside i dump all that into trash
can we've never done science on planet
earth
okay that's what this site says you
don't have to agree with me
we're not asking you to agree
we want you to listen to understand and
reach our own conclusions okay so i told
them that i had a new version of science
my version of science was rational
explanations
now in uh in in that definition there do
you see any provision for math
and do you see any provisions for
experiments
now he had no problem with the math part
for whatever reason he never really went
into we never went into that in any
depth so he said okay he kind of liked
that but when we went into experiments
we got into a lot of trouble
there was a lot of crying you know
we got into a little bit of uh
interruptions and
uh
you know exchange of words and so on not
that we went off the rails but uh we
didn't see eye to eye obviously and so
what was the issue with the experiments
again in a nutshell we also discussed
the issue of knowledge that we're going
to be dealing with today and what was
the issue with uh with experiments well
i said what experiment can you run
and this goes also for the flat earthers
who insist
on experiments
uh electric universers also insist on
experiments you know more than more than
the establishment actually the
establishment likes to do a lot of
so-called theoretical physics they do a
lot of thought experiments and a lot of
these uh
fringe groups they don't like that they
say no we want an experiment to prove to
verify to demonstrate etc etc and i said
experiments have nothing to do with a
scientific method or with science
and it blew his mind what do you mean we
need to verify we need to prove we need
to know
that's how we got into the word
knowledge and i said okay what
experiments do you propose to
detect for invisible intangible entities
what is an experiment an experiment is
see
touch
that's what an experiment is see touch
you go to the lab to see and to touch
but now we have all these invisible
intangible entities you cannot see you
cannot touch
what experiment does any of these
fringe groups right
flat earthers electric universes even
the establishment what do they propose
to detect that which you cannot see and
that which you cannot touch
and that's where it comes down to a
little bit of what we're going to be
dealing with today the fact that all
these people say that an object is that
which you can see touch
and that which exists is that which you
can see touch
and we're saying none of that
all those definitions those notions are
irrational
an object is not that which you can see
or touch
existence is not that which you can see
or touch and that's where we run into
trouble and so i said well how do you
what experiment do you propose to detect
something which you cannot see or touch
also by the way ratified by the
establishment at cern and slack and
fermilab and all these accelerators they
say we can't see or touch what's in
there
and so they go into concepts it was mass
it was charged it was energy so they get
into all the they they mediate all these
transactions with abstract mathematical
concepts and people don't realize that
uh basically laymen they think they're
talking about things
they think that uh energy is a thing
mass is a thing force is a thing so when
these people say well the particle of
electromagnetism you know the photon or
whatever they say okay i understand it's
a little ball
that's what they're thinking of
and they don't realize that ball really
represents a number what they're doing
is accelerating a number and people
don't catch that okay
so i said so so the establishment also
is in accordance that there are
invisible intangible entities
or at least that there's something
invisible or intangible in that region
that you know they cannot account for
and they just go into concepts
that's what's happening and so i'm
saying what if you have to detect one of
these invisible intangible entities what
experiment are you going to run
and he did not understand that at all i
guess again because you think a thing is
that which you can see or touch
existence is that which you can see or
touch they are synonyms existence and
objects and things
and so he had no answer at the same time
he kind of brushed it aside because it
didn't click in his brain
he didn't know what i was saying
and so um i continued with that line of
briefing i said how do you define
science in such a way
as to include
right
uh those phenomena we cannot see or
touch
[Music]
and because i said you can define
science any way you want but now you if
you're if you're going to say that
gravity
and say magnetism electricity the
workings of the atom if those are part
of physics
and physics is part of science how do
you define science in order to
incorporate
those uh those phenomena
and
he had no answer to that uh he just went
with what we have and he just kept going
back to
uh knowledge to truth to verification
to experiments and i couldn't get him
out of that and he just tried to impose
that idea on me he wasn't really
interviewing me at that point it was
just kind of like a shouting match more
or less we didn't get into shouting but
it's like we interrupted each other
constantly and he finally called it
quits and never put the video up
so yeah you won't find anything out
there
i don't have a copy of it he hasn't
called me back he i think he was upset
at me that i ruined his show
so that's all i can tell you there's
nothing there okay
uh later on i went up there and
found out some of his definitions
uh went to his site i hadn't gone to his
site previously but then i went to his
side and found these definitions and i
realized then why we didn't see eye to
eye
especially on the issue of knowledge
that we're going to be dealing with
today i told them knowledge was belief
belief was knowledge and lots of lots of
people have problems with that out there
because they've been
drilled in high school and college that
knowledge is something different than
believe but they don't really know
exactly what it is but they say
knowledge is different
and today we're going to be dealing with
that but you can see his definitions
there and they're not very good in the
case of belief it's uh to accept
something that's true where true is
again a belief
and what is now it's awareness of some
fact where fact is also a an opinion a a
a belief
and so
these are two words are synonyms and
people don't like me saying that okay
then uh obviously he said reality is
that which exists and the universe is
all that exists
that's like saying god is everything
okay and again those definitions are
worthless they you can't use those in
science
uh again fact and myth uh you can see
there again uh what someone says proven
in the case of fact and myth is what is
a false belief
and they're all the same thing because
what the way they really look at this is
that
you know what what i know i know what
you know is a belief
that's the way they look at it uh every
person looks at everybody else in the
universe or at least here on planet
earth and says i know what i know but
you what you believe what you think you
know that's the way everybody looks at
this
and uh yeah you find out that he was a
follower of ayn rand and that also
explains a lot because ain't rand
was not a philosopher she had no clue
about anything okay i'm going to talk
about her today i'm going to try to
destroy her in every possible way i can
especially those people who say or think
that
and that i'm saying the same thing that
ain't rand said
and if they say that it's because they
don't understand what this site is about
what i've been saying all these years
okay no
i say absolutely nothing even similar to
ing ran inran said everything that every
so-called philosopher traditional
philosophers said before she did she
didn't change anything whatsoever
nothing
and i'm saying something different than
all of them and until you understand
that difference well then you're going
to say the same thing you're going to
say dude you're saying the same thing as
a rand
no and so the first thing i want to
mention here is that what i said the
other day that you got to get rid of all
your heroes
you know i had to get rid of heroes and
if you look at the previous uh lecture i
talked about that uh you got to get rid
of some of these heroes they're not
heroes okay and i had to get rid of one
hero
and that was carl sagan
he was an atheist
and i was an atheist at the time he was
he believed in that we would go to the
stars
and i more or less agreed with him that
i thought that we were going to colonize
first the planets and move out of the
solar system conquer one star maybe once
star system a planet somewhere and from
there move on to other stars eventually
conquer the galaxies and eventually
conquer the universe you know that's
that's the train of thought
and
so i pondered the issue of whether
anyone had already come to earth you had
fondant in and his
ideas that you know the pyramids were
built by uh extraterrestrials and so on
at the time and so i was involved in
that i didn't believe in any of that uh
but um you know that subject was very
popular at the time it's less popular i
think today
and you know with a with uh carl sagan
on the one side talking about uh you
know
going out there
then you give the possibility that maybe
you know the et's have already come down
here or
can come down here you know so you at
least concede the possibility
and then you run into fermi's paradox
which all the
all of those you of you who heard about
it you know is that you know
i haven't seen any
extraterrestrials here if uh
if you should imagine that or some
civilizations there are much more
advanced than we are so why aren't the
klingons here that's the issue you know
and so yeah i had to delete carl sagan
as a uh as a hero of mine
uh because of two reasons but then carl
sagan was not even a physicist
he he believed in quantum mechanics and
general relativity i don't know if he
was into
string theory i never researched that in
in his case because i i can't him a long
time ago carl sagan was not a physicist
he was a religious fanatic in other
words an atheist
and these people are more fanatic than
religious folk
and he also believed we were going to
the stars and likewise i can only urge
you to abandon enrand she was not a
philosopher she tried to do physics she
failed at that miserably she didn't do
physics at all
and
she was also a religious fanatic she was
an atheist okay and all she did was
politics all she did is recommend how
people should behave and live
okay
so that's my take on good old ain
as some people called her
and carl sagan so
and engrained was never a hero of mine
but you know i got rid of both of them
yeah i don't think they were
physicists they weren't philosophers
they they were just in the case of a
ranch it was just a politician
that's the way i look at that
anyways uh let's move on with the
subject matter today i'm going to start
um where i left off the other day and
that's with philosophy okay why because
some people had some issues with
philosophy
and one fellow raises this question i'm
going to start with his
uh criticism or his um
counter definition
for philosophy which is more or less
what people have out there okay here it
is he said philosophy is the search for
truth
the best route to truth is the
scientific method
okay uh so what is he saying i mean
aside from the fact that he's talking
about truth i'm going to just
skip over that
uh he's saying essentially philosophy is
a branch of science okay because he's
saying it's a search for truth and you
get to that truth through the scientific
method so he's putting philosophy under
science under the scientific method then
he continues he says science applies
the data to philosophy for philosophical
speculation again he's putting
philosophy under science he's putting it
as a branch of science
but then he goes in there he puts uh
something that puts philosophy between
the sciences philosophy takes the
results of various scientific
investigations and systematizes them as
a whole science is isolated from one
another unless they are coordinated and
unified by philosophy now he puts it as
a middleman as a go between the sciences
and how does he conclude he says science
is conceived from
philosophy and is thus dependent on its
theories to begin with
so he went full circle around now he put
science as a branch of science uh
philosophy
and uh and this ends up with what people
understand as philosophy being a
philosophy being the mother of sciences
okay so this is a contradiction they
live with these contradictions they
don't realize what they're saying
because they don't analyze what they're
saying
and so yeah the but uh the
the punchline is the best one of all the
this uh fellow goes up there and he says
philosophy cannot be defined precisely
because the subject is so complex and so
controversial
different philosophers have different
views of the nature methods and range of
philosophy
so after defining philosophy and saying
first that it's uh under science and
ending up with
um it's
over science then he says oh by the way
you know we can't really define
philosophy very well
or better yet at all
and that's where we are today okay we
are today at that point where nobody has
ever defined the word philosophy in fact
i mentioned the other day that the
stanford encyclopedia of
philosophy right
the only word you won't find defined in
there is the word philosophy
and you would think it's the first word
you're going to define if you're going
to talk about that discipline are you
going to make an encyclopedia of the
discipline and no they haven't defined
the word philosophy you can look for it
on your own okay go to stanford
encyclopedia philosophy you will not
find the word philosophy
okay another uh visitor uh relating to
ayn rand again
also uh
tries to defend her as a philosopher
which i'm gonna attack today again
says the following enran developed a
philosophy for living
there's no such monster as a philosophy
of living or for living now what uh
philosophy for living is is just a
recommendation saying you should live
this way that's not known as a
philosopher as known as your next-door
neighbor
that's known as the government they tell
you how you should live okay
so philosophy is not a way of thinking
which is the notion
the common man has out there you ask him
what is philosophy well it's his
philosophy it's my philosophy they're
talking about a way of thinking that's
our philosophy because if that's
philosophy we have eight billion
philosophers on earth and you cannot
distinguish aristotle from you or ayn
ran from you okay so you can't use that
as a definition as a notion of what
philosophy is you must take the trouble
to sit down for a whole day and try to
define the word philosophy then you can
use the word consistently scientifically
rationally but if you just it's a way of
thinking you haven't said anything okay
and uh so um
philosophy is also not a recommendation
how to live none of that that's known as
politics politics is religion not
philosophy or physics okay how do we
define philosophy rational explanations
of behaviors it's in sciences rational
explanations philosophy is one of the
branches the other one being physics
and
this uh visitor says you are whether you
like it or not a philosopher of science
no such monster as a philosopher of
science a philosopher of physics that
that's nonsense that was created by the
mathematicians the mathematical
physicists they talk in those terms okay
um
no
it's
philosophy of science is not a branch of
philosophy we have science and we have
physics and philosophy under them that's
the way it works okay
so science is not a branch of philosophy
and philosophy
is uh a branch of science one of the uh
two branches of science and then this
person continues the branches of
philosophy are and
says metaphysics epistemology ethics
politics aesthetics no philosophy
branches are psychology history
anthropology sociology animal behavior
and it continues in other words when
you're talking about explaining behavior
then you're doing philosophy in any
discipline that falls under science okay
that's what we say here okay
and um
what do people say well they say the
following okay so uh i'll preempt you
okay they say fine i don't like your
definition of philosophy bill
okay why don't you like my definition i
thought it was a pretty definition you
tell me you don't like it and so people
raise some of these arguments they say
it's not the one i learned in college
well that's a fallacy of authority or
they say it's your personal definition
no one voted for it that's the fallacy
of democracy
and someone might say well the etymology
where does it come from philosophy comes
from the greek love of wisdom and they
say the world uses different notion of
philosophy than you we've used this for
hundreds of years well that's the
fallacy of tradition
you can't use any of these arguments to
defend yourself
what you need to come up with is a
definition i came up with a definition
philosophy rational explanations of
behaviors you don't like it come up with
a better mousetrap defend your mousetrap
get in the ring and defend it you can't
use the fallacy of authority democracy
or tradition to defend your notion of
you know what it is uh what philosophy
is
now uh if you go in there you find this
you find the uh definition that you find
in
the wikipedia and other places and they
said philosophy the study of fundamental
nature of what knowledge so philosophy
deals with knowledge right in fact love
of knowledge right
reality and existence
but it turns out that uh existence and
reality are synonyms together with
actuality and being so what have we
learned uh you're just using synonyms
and knowledge is belief is that what's
the philosophy studies belief
okay
and uh so we'll get to that in a minute
to show that knowledge is belief but uh
if if i am able to make my case then
yeah philosophy is not the study of
knowledge reality or existence has
nothing to do with any of that in fact
reality existence belong exclusively to
physics it is physics that deals with
what exists out there
and uh how it behaves uh from a
mechanistic point of view okay
um
and then another definition there you'll
find uh
this one from the wikipedia the first
one was from another site this one says
from wikipedia the study again study we
don't study because in science because
anybody can study and not know
get a zero in the test so we don't use
the word study to define any discipline
it says of general and fundamental
questions such as
what existence reason knowledge values
mind and language okay they put a few
more but again and they have existence
and knowledge in there and what is
existence well it's the again from the
wikipedia okay the ability of an entity
to interact with reality but it turns
out that it reality is a synonym of
existence all they did it was put in
a synonym to define existence what is a
synonym it's a circular definition or no
definition at all
it refers to the ontological property of
being whatever that is okay let's find
out what it is ontology it's a branch of
philosophy that studies what existence
being becoming in reality all which are
synonyms we haven't learned a single
thing so far from all these people
okay
and now what is interesting about this
is that when you look up knowledge okay
uh it turns out that they don't use as
synonyms like when you go to the uh
tesseras uh they don't put the synonym
of knowledge as belief which they should
no one put belief as a synonym but it
turns out when you look for the animals
they put unbelief
so that was funny i thought
let me get rid of this give me a second
here
here we go
so um knowledge
they don't put belief as a synonym but
they put unbelief as an antonym so you
figure out
okay so uh
here we have a different definition
okay
and it's the one that i use okay and you
see it there for for philosophy right
and
you see how it falls within science what
is science rational explanations see
about in two
parts one is physics the other one is
philosophy that's it there's no more
there's no other category physics deals
with explanations of phenomena it deals
with causes and mechanisms philosophy
deals with rational explanations of what
behaviors and it deals with reasons and
purposes
now you can have a definition you can
take to the bank okay
and uh
you know i can defend those definitions
because
they're all related they're all related
to the definition of science as rational
explanations what is it that we want to
know in physics which is what we deal
with in this channel we want to
understand how the universe works we
want to know specifically understand no
we don't want to believe we want to
understand we understand how gravity
works
we understand
why in the case of philosophy why
someone did something or why an animal
behave in a certain way those are the
questions of science people want to
understand
it doesn't mean that you're going to
believe which is what mathematical
physics harps upon they want you to
believe and so they come and they try to
prove to you with evidence so that they
know so that you
know meaning you believe
that's what it's all about and we don't
do that in science science has to be
objective meaning
you explain a mechanism in the case of
physics so that people understand
what you're proposing as far as the
mechanism
and we don't run experiments like this
uh file said uh science critic
because we can't run any experiment to
detect invisible intangible entities
we're done that's it so you have to
define science in a way that you
encapsulate include those phenomena the
invisible intangible ones okay and so
whatever you define science whatever you
define physics as
hopefully it includes
uh a an understanding of
invisible intangible phenomena okay or
objects that mediate
the the invisible intangible objects
that mediate
phenomena we can't see
or touch we don't see the mechanism okay
that's the issue
okay another fella comes here and he has
this notion he says the fine also again
about ain rand
says the a is a thing
rand is huge on this okay a is a makes a
lot of sense you know a is a
i love asa uh what does he call the uh
law as they call it the law of identity
okay
it's uh her way of saying um
uh shoot the observer in a way in any
sense right
i don't know if that's what that is okay
this is what ayn rand actually says okay
regarding all this uh
especially existence because he got into
the
issue of existence whoever touches the
word exist the word entity whether
knowingly or not has
crossed the line into physics
they're not doing philosophy anymore
they're not doing ontology epistemology
or
or any or metaphysics any of that
nonsense there's no such monsters as
those now when you touch the word exist
when you touch the word entity meaning
thing meaning object you've crossed the
line into physics those words belong
exclusively to physics and we don't have
10 definitions for them we have
one
you don't like the definition you gotta
get inside the ring with your definition
sword and shield defend it okay we're
gonna try to smash whatever you come
up there with
okay so what did ayn rand said she said
the primary the primacy of existence of
reality is the axiom that what existence
exists
absolutely love that yeah i call it word
wizardry
that's what it is you know existence
exists oh man i need a beer to
understand that one
that the universe exists
the universe
there's no such physical object as the
universe you should not never put an
article in front of the word universe a
universe the universe because there's no
such monster in physics i mean you can
do that in ordinary speech in the course
of
a debate a discussion but let's make
sure that when we go back we get rid of
that article articles can only be placed
in front of objects the only objects the
only things that can serve as nouns and
physics are things
objects things then you can put an
article in front you can't say the
energy you cannot say a force
those are not physical objects and orbit
you can't use any of those you can't
talk like that in physics now we do that
anyways in the course of discussion no
problem but as long as we understand
that you cannot use those as physical
objects and that's part of the problem
with the language okay
so uh existence exists that's an
irrational it's just word wizardry
universe exists well that's irrational
you cannot say that the universe exists
okay not in physics not in science you
can do that in ordinary speech and
religion
fine not in physics not in science why
because the universe is a concept
okay so this word universe is a concept
and concepts don't exist you cannot say
that a concept exists not in physics not
in science you can do that in ordinary
speech you can say love exists
intelligence exists
fine but you can't do that in physics in
physics only objects may be said to
exist that follows from the definition
of the word exist
okay
and
we'll get in there you have the
definition exist existence what is it
physical presence
what is physical refer to
a thing an object an entity a body a
substance whatever you want to call it
there all those are synonyms
presence that's location it must have
location there has to be distance
between that thing and my chest in order
for it to meet the definition of exist
you can't do that with the word universe
because universe is matter and space
that's why universe is not a thing
the universe is a concept okay
and yeah a lot of people have problems
with that
um and then she said she continued a
thing is itself
a is a right
existence is identity
no we have a problem with that a serious
problem it's an irrational statement
what she just said
a thing is itself is nonsense it's
poppycock that's a law of identity a
equal a that's for people who have to go
to a mental asylum okay it has no
meaning whatsoever in physics to say
that
the ball is the ball
no kid yeah
uh i don't know what that could possibly
mean existence is identity absolutely
not because if identity is a thing it's
is itself
they're not finished existence is not
identity it's identity plus location you
need location for it to be existing
and that's what all these people missed
including ayn rand and everyone that
came before her and after by the way
okay
things are what they are an identity and
again the universe is not the universe i
mean whatever that means a universe is
not an object not a thing it's an
unscientific um statement
uh existence
can only apply to objects and it cannot
apply to concepts okay and if you want
to use the word exist
in a rational manner it had better have
an object and it had and that object had
better have location
okay and so here's a more or less a
summary
of why in rand just chased her tail
around didn't come up with anything
because she was trying to do physics
whether she knew it or not and she ended
up with nonsense and what is the
nonsense the nonsense is that
she said that the universe is
beyond consciousness in other words you
don't need consciousness for the
universe to exist that's the way she put
it
and then everything she said after that
included conscience including see touch
feeling
senses
meaning consciousness so she she
contradicted herself that's all she did
in her reasoning and here it is i'm put
uh show you why she did a circular
reasoning okay
and why she did not nothing different
than human can't for example two two
folks that beat her to it okay she
starts out by saying the universe exists
independent of consciousness well we
can't say the universe exists but we
understand what she's saying she's
saying like the matter out there you
know every atom in the universe is out
there independent of consciousness okay
no problem there but this is not what
she says in the rest of her
dissertation she says consciousness is
the faculty of perceiving that which
exists
she talks about perception now she's
going to introduce c and touch
okay she says first it's independent of
consciousness meaning of c and touch now
she's going to talk about perception she
introduces see and touch back into her
discussion
and now she says the most uh ridiculous
thing ever to exist is to be something
absolutely not this is the same thing
that hume said and the same thing that
kant said
and there's her own words a thing is
itself existence is identity if
existence is a thing meaning identity
meaning itself we're missing the word
location
that's what human can't miss and that's
what ain't ran missed she did not figure
out the word location that's that's
what's missing in the word exist
and then she said something is this
which one perceives absolutely not you
don't perceive the rope you can't see or
touch the mediators of gravity or of uh
light or of uh magnetism so this is not
true you cannot say that something
exists which one perceives aside from
the fact that perception is a personal
uh issue you know if i'm on drugs and i
can't perceive because you know i'm
floating out there you know
what does that tell me about uh
existence does that mean that uh the
table exists for you because you can
perceive it you can touch it and see it
and you know i'm in left field with my
mind and i can't see her or touch it
because you know
i'm flying in cloud nine does that mean
that the table doesn't exist
it's a question of perception of of each
individual is it subjective what she
called objectivism and all she does is a
subjectivism then she says existence and
consciousness are axioms you cannot
escape absolutely not existence has
nothing to do whatsoever with
consciousness and that's what she said
at the beginning that it's independent
of consciousness
and then she she just rubs in more of
that she says something needs sight and
or touch absolutely not awareness of
entities sight and touch absolutely not
perceive things entity she talked about
perception about consciousness about sea
touch and as long as she um
went into sea touch she just
went around in circles in her reasoning
so no um n ryan never figured it out
first because she was dealing with the
subject matters she was not
very familiar with which was physics she
didn't realize that existence and entity
belong to physics exclusively so she was
not doing philosophy uh philosophy of
living of life or whatever it's called
recommendations on how to live whatever
you want to call it none of that is
physic none of that is philosophy that's
just religion just just an opinion
opinion uh beliefs that's
a religion okay
and uh some people say well bill what
are you saying you're saying that
the universe
the
universe
is a concept so
we're living inside or within
a concept
is that what you're saying bill
and again it's because people have um
they don't have a very irrational mind
so they don't know what the issues are
so let's make sure we answer that
question okay for those who still have
uh stumbling blocks mental mental blocks
to understand that issue so let's go
with that okay universe is a concept yes
concept a word that invokes or embodies
two objects or two words treated as
objects so the fellow says
are you suggesting that we live inside a
concept we're living without within a
concept and this is important also for
the flat earthers who say you know uh
what do you mean um you can you can
curve water without a container
you know so to speak so it's like
they're suggesting that
you know the universe is some kind of
container space is some kind of
container that's what they're
insinuating that's what they have in the
backs of their minds
and so we have to go slowly for these
people and say universe we define it as
matter and space
okay matter and space matters all the
atoms out there okay in existence they
have distance with respect to each other
each one has location that's independent
of consciousness true like uh nissan
rand said
and the other portion of the word
universe is space so what is space
well space is a synonym of nothing
and that is that which has no shape
an object is that which has shape space
is that which does not have shape if it
doesn't have shape it doesn't have a
border it doesn't have a surface
it doesn't have a perimeter and so not
even god can get out of without which
doesn't have shape there's no border to
cross okay so space is not a container
it's not a thing
okay
and so the issue is the atom the way you
have to look at this is the atoms in
your body form part of the matter that
comprises the so-called universe
universe is matter in space your your
atoms form part of the matter it's not
contained within any uh
container okay
it's floating in nothingness there is no
such thing as space there is no such
thing as
uh nothing nothingness and so you cannot
escape
nothingness you can't no adam can leave
space because it would have nowhere to
go because there's no place to cross
there is no border to cross not even god
can escape space okay
and so uh
to say that we inhabit or live within
the universe is what the irrational
statement is
okay so this the way you're supposed to
look at that
under
rational physics rational science okay
uh visitor says continue with this line
of reasoning okay
religion is mysticism no absolutely not
in fact if you look up the word well you
could say it is uh mysticism is belief
that's that's essentially how it's
defined but uh really just want to
clarify that religion has nothing to do
with god
okay religion has to do with opinion and
belief and that's what yeah mysticism is
and atheism is a religion
okay why because and i say it's the
religion of the mathematicians a person
who is an atheist is a person who does
not understand the scientific method has
never done science in their lives that's
what a an atheist is
why where's the problem the problem is
that an atheist says i don't believe in
the existence of god
the deist theist
they say i believe in the existence of
god and the agnostic says i don't know
whether to believe in the existence of
god or not and something along those
lines all three of them are irrational
statements are irrational people
the way we do it in science we say let
us assume
that god exists
god can never be a theory to you you
cannot say that you believe or don't
believe in the theory of god's existence
god cannot be a
a
a theory god can only be a thing you can
say god is a thing
okay and that's if god has shape now if
god is a concept you cannot even talk
about existence you cannot say god
exists because god is intelligence or
god is love that's even worse but if god
is a thing like a human you know the guy
with the magic one that made the
universe fine no problem you you start
out on the right foot now you have an
object now in order for god to exist i
don't care if you believe or don't
believe or are not sure none of that has
any bearing on the on the issue before
us the issue before us is does
uh
god fit the definition of exist of
existence
for that god has to be an object
apparently he's an objective he's a
human right so we've got an object a
thing but now he's got to have uh
location he's got to have distance with
respect to my chest
god can hide in the 20th dimension for
all we care there has to be a straight
line of direction from god all the way
to me
so he can hide anywhere he wants i don't
care but he's if he exists there's got
to be a straight line of direction from
god to me
and he cannot escape that no matter what
dimension he wishes to hide in okay
uh
person says morality and politics are
not religion yeah they are
morality is an opinion okay i i kill
your brother is that moral or what
is that uh
you know your opinion well i think it is
because you know i think it was good and
you think it was bad i i think it was
moral i had to kill him
maybe he did something to me and so i
thought it was good to kill him and you
think it's bad to kill him so what have
we learned about morality
and uh you know
we've had um
homosexuality for centuries considered
uh
immoral
now it's not
now it's part of the mainstream so the
question is
what are we going to say we have an
opinion about it is that what it is
um one that ain't randa used to say uses
altruism is is that moral or immoral i
mean you can go on and on just pick up
any word and uh you'll find one person
on one side of the issue another one on
the other side of the issue we haven't
learned anything
and politics obviously is religion
because politics is all opinion how we
should run the world
and someone says well there's a better
way of running the world or more
effective way of running the world
than uh in another way okay so you have
uh the way of running it uh we'll call
it
uh form a and form b you know there's a
way a of doing things a way b of doing
thing
and
the guys i see with with the way a were
more productive or more efficient blah
blah blah blah blah
and the other person might say yeah but
look uh people are more miserable and so
on he might raise some other issues
and so what have we learned it's just an
opinion
you know
again what we look for in science is
explanations
and not opinions of or recommendations
of how to run the world or how you
should behave or whatever that's known
again as your next door neighbor he
tells you how you should behave or the
government you know any of those and ran
derived her views scientifically
well no such monster you know how views
are derived is irrelevant first of all i
don't care if you had a bad dream or you
did an experiment you can derive your
views any way you want it's when you
come to the conference you have to
explain
something
not how you came to your conclusions i
mean if you want to put that as as an
interesting uh anecdote that's great but
the meat of it is the explanation not
how you came to your
your conclusions and then her views you
know her views that's an opinion
yeah i don't care what her views are we
need an explanation and again all she
did was
again politics
recommendations on how to live
not philosophy philosophy explanations
and again we have to define the word
philosophy in order to categorize her
properly and then the perceptual
concretes of existence again when you
get into
perception you get into not objectivity
which is what she called her
subjectivity yeah perception is
subjective
so
why she says on the one hand
that the universe exists outside of
consciousness
and then she goes in and says the only
way to determine what exists out there
is through see touch perception
consciousness so she she just went
around in circles that's all she did and
again because she was not a philosopher
she was not a scientist she was not a
physicist which is what she tried to do
whether she knew it or not
okay let's get to well um i just wanna i
guess before i get into knowledge just
wanna
uh summarize what this site is about
okay and again we're not asking you to
believe
to share our knowledge
our beliefs we're asking you to
understand what this site is about okay
and it takes a long time for people to
understand what this site is about
because we're very different than
everybody else out there we say
absolutely nothing like anybody out
there on the planet okay here it is
rational science we have a paradigm
shift major paradigm shift
we're breaking completely with the past
anything um below the year 2000 and
backwards is was nonsense we never did
science we never did philosophy because
we never defined those words we never
did physics you know
and uh to this day we have no definition
from the establishment okay for physics
or for philosophy
and no one from aristotle to aim right
none of those figured it out why because
they had no definition see if they would
have defined the terms we could use them
consistently and apply them
but since they never define these words
very precisely very concisely so that we
can use them consistently scientifically
rationally because of that they were not
scientists they were not philosophers
they were not physics they're outside of
all that okay uh all they did was
politics recommendations and they say
this how you should live this is what
you should do
you know your next-door neighbor and um
uh all they
ended up
with today and that's the proof the
evidence you want proof evidence truth
here you have it
what do we have today we have irrational
notions of how the universe works what
do we have we have no definitions uh we
confuse physics with philosophy we think
that existence and entities belong to
philosophy ontology epistemology and all
that stuff no those words belong
exclusively to physics and so people say
i'm a philosopher oh why are you a
philosopher oh because i i try to figure
out what exists and what an entity is
what a thing is
in fact those words are treated within
the world of philosophy and the people
who should be treating with that
with those words
don't do it and those are the physicists
so-called physicists mathematical
physicists they say no we do equations
that's all we do
and so yeah entities existence they
don't belong to philosophy
and until you get a hang of that you
don't know what this site is about so
we've changed all that and we don't care
what the rest of the world says we don't
care we're the only
uh people on the planet who hold those
views this is not about tradition it's
not about democracy it's not about
authority it's about defining words that
no one has defined until today
and again the issue there is that these
words are up for grabs
uh no one has defined them so you're
welcome to define them today uh if you
go to the dictionary go to the
encyclopedias you won't find rational
definitions you'll find all kinds of
problems with them even though the same
philosophers
epistemologies whatever they're called
the physics they'll tell you the same
thing well we don't have a really a
definition we don't know what a point is
we don't know what a line is they have
no definitions for these we don't know
what time is they don't know any of
these words they don't have a definition
but they use them
and when you ask them well what's the
definition of this he said go to the
other side of campus ask a librarian ask
uh english major and he'll tell you you
know
and you go to them and they say we'll go
to the dictionary we defined it there
when you go in there you find irrational
definitions that's all you find
inconsistent definitions
and if you go
again with the word philosophy to the
stanford encyclopedia philosophy you
won't even find the word
so
whatever these words are up for grabs
you can anyone is welcome to define them
now because whatever you find in the
dictionaries are not rational are not
defensible
okay and from this from
philosophy we lead into knowledge what
is knowledge
well we all think we know we all think
uh knowledge different than belief today
i'm going to argue exactly the opposite
i'm going to maintain what plato
maintained
uh 2 500 years ago that knowledge is
belief and he couldn't tell the
difference in the end after doing all
his uh footwork okay he could figure it
out okay so uh one person says comes in
here and says
you are unfortunately using plato in his
justified true belief crap
i love that okay
okay but uh yeah plato said knowledge is
belief but uh and i say the same thing
there's no difference between knowledge
and belief a lot of people don't like to
hear me say that okay uh
i feel for you
in my heart
so what you need to do is define
knowledge not tell me what it ain't tell
me what it is okay that's what what
you're tasked with okay you got to tell
me what knowledge is
and for this uh let's make sure we
at least um cross the t and dot the i
there that we cover mr plato so that i
mean he he really covered the word uh
the word knowledge quite well okay
being covered in uh this book okay
it's called the uh theaters
uh and he says uh socrates he's got this
discussion among socrates and his
students a couple visitors that came in
there and came
and um
socrates says what is knowledge
and theaters says he who knows perceives
what he knows knowledge is
perception
perception again enrand she talked about
perception every one of these people
talks about perception see touch
okay see touch
perception senses
that's what they thought an object is
all these years that's what they
identify existence with
so knowledge is very much related to the
word exist
existence and the word entity object
thing okay
we're gonna see that constantly these
three words are constantly intertwined
okay
so what does socrates say well he's got
three arguments essentially those are
not his exact words i'm just gonna put
his
uh conclusions this is plato uh speaking
for socrates who by then had uh
been forced to commit suicide okay
he was forced to drink hemlock for uh
corrupting the use and offending the
gods of
greece
and so this is what socrates says he
says perception is inseparable from the
perceiver
yeah
okay perception perceiver it's like they
go together senses see touch see touch
see touch
but he makes a good argument he says uh
there's a problem of memory why because
when the perception is gone
right you you touch something now
a minute later you're no longer
perceiving that thing but you have it in
memory
and so now you're not perceiving
directly but you have the memory of the
perception
and as he says if if knowledge is
perception is the
knowledge gone now that you no longer
perceive no longer see touch now you
have it in your mind
okay that's the argument he raises okay
this is a train of thought okay
and then uh
plato again speaking for socrates says
other people may misperceive okay
in other words uh someone may have the
wrong perception again he could be on
drugs he could be flying high
he could be out of his mind
and does that mean that we have to trust
his perception
you know so again you got to keep all
these things in mind that
um these are the arguments that uh plato
raised
okay and uh so this is uh what uh
plato concludes essentially you know he
says uh that book theaters says
knowledge a true judgment with an
account that's essentially his
conclusion
and
that's translated today as justified
true belief what is knowledge belief
ultimately belief especially when uh
justified and true
are synonyms of belief so justified is
belief
true is belief
and belief is belief so all he said is
knowledge is belief belief belief that's
all he said it's just a lot of belief
and
he tried to put in there you know when
you say justified true belief uh you're
you're kind of including something which
is external like there's a truth out
there okay
and you have a belief
and the question is whether
knowledge is that belief in that truth
that is out there
but if that truth we you know we all
have different truths we all have
different proofs in our head we have
different evidences
for the same thing you know some one
says well god exists the other one says
god doesn't exist
and i have the proven he has the proof
as well so you know uh
is god truth
well it all comes down back to belief
you can't escape belief and so the fact
that you say well there's a truth out
there
yeah yeah you can say that mother nature
father universe you know they know what
the truth is they know what exactly
happened
but we don't have access to their file
cabinet
so
every person eight billion people on
earth we all have different notions of
what actually happened
okay so we have our beliefs
and that truth becomes a belief after
the fact
okay so
mother nature and father universe they
know exactly what happens what is they
know that
you can say they know okay but we we can
only guess we can only have our beliefs
and we call that belief knowledge
because i'm certain of it i'm convinced
of it
but you are not
so we have beliefs so yeah even though
truth suggests something external okay
like mother nature knows the truth yeah
but we don't have access to that truth
we only have our version of the truth
our version of the fact is a belief so
we have his belief
now this comes back down to belief and
when you look up the word belief what do
you find well something one accepts as
true and or real
uh a firmly held opinion
sounds quite a bit like knowledge you
know when you know something well you
know it
no one's going to take you out of there
because you know it
you're certain of it you know
that it happened or that it is
and someone else tries to convince you
of the opposite you know says no no look
that's not what happened that's not what
it is say no but i know it
means you believe it you believe you
just when you know you believe more
strongly that's all
you just believe more strongly what what
you know that's all it is because when
you know that means you have nothing to
learn because you've already learned
that you no one can shake you out of
your knowledge
meaning it's and now there's just a
stronger belief that's all it is okay
that's what it comes down to and you
look at the synonyms for belief and it
says trust faith opinion conviction
judgment dogma
sounds like knowledge
right quite quite like now i don't see a
difference but if you do
all you have to do is define the word
knowledge and then maybe we can get the
ball rolling here because if you think
that knowledge is anything other than
belief
which is what everyone from
from plato to our days
all these people who study knowledge out
there all the philosophers so-called
philosophers
you know if if if after 3000 years they
concluded that there's no difference
between plato and what we have today
meaning knowledge is belief
then if you have something different
then
your job is to
define it in such a way that you can
defend it and say i can show you how
knowledge is different than belief
and you have to do that through
definitions you know don't don't give me
a long explanation just define it and
that that will do you know show me how
knowledge is different than belief
anyways um these are the conclusions we
find today okay out there this is from
the wikipedia socrates and he theaters
uh discuss three definitions of
knowledge okay knowledge is nothing but
perception it's a
true judgment and true judgment with an
account and then it uh summarizes says
each of these definitions is shown to be
unsatisfactory
uh what does the stanford encyclopedia
of philosophy word that they never
define say
the official conclusion of the theaters
is that we still do not know how to
define knowledge
okay
so that's out of plato they're just
analyzing play-doh let's see if they've
done any better since plato okay and you
go out there and this is what you find
okay again knowledge is familiarity or
awareness of someone or something
what does that mean what is familiarity
or awareness
and there is wide
agreement among philosophers that it is
a form of true
belief
what is now is it's belief okay that's
after 3 000 years this is their
conclusion what's dictionary.com say
knowledge acquaintance with facts truths
or principles acquaintance what is it
known to one
that sounds like belief
okay and yeah there's a summary uh
familiarity acquaintance with being
aware
uh is that what knowledge is
because if that's what it is yeah it's
uh
personal subjective and meaning it's
belief
we still haven't
you know gotten out of belief
here's the stanford encyclopedia of
philosophy that's what they say about
knowledge the analysis says traditional
approaches to knowledge habit that
knowledge has to do with factors like
truth and justification meaning what
belief okay whether knowledge requires
safety sensitivity reliability or
independence from certain
kinds of luck has proven controversial
but something that all these potential
conditions on knowledge seem to have in
common is that they have some sort of
intimate connection with belief
although it is admittedly difficult to
make the relevant connection precise
there is an intuitive sense in which
every factor we've examined as a
candidate for being relevant to
knowledge has something to do with
beliefs
so what have we concluded after 3 000
years after analyzing the gettier
problem and all these other nonsense
things that they put in there
knowledge is belief
okay
you don't like it because you think down
is something different
define it
don't tell me that i'm wrong don't tell
me that i got the wrong references
define it show me that knowledge is not
belief okay
uh remove the word belief or any synonym
with belief from your definition
okay and this is what ayn rand said
about knowledge okay we gotta
touch her as well because she
touched the word
knowledge is a mental grasp whoa she's
going to be touching the mind
that's great she mentally grasps
something whatever that means i mean how
you
you know they use these physical terms
to define
a concept an abstract concept such as
knowledge
of a fact of reality what is a fact it's
belief because whatev whatever is a fact
of reality is your personal opinion
that's how it is
reached either by what perceptual
observation what is perceived opinion
what is observed opinion
so or by a process of reason based on
perceptual observation
so uh again all she gave us is the word
belief in different ways she gave us
opinion which is again a belief
recommendations that's all she did which
is belief
it's all belief
enran uh was not a philosopher she was
not a knower of or a lover of knowledge
all she did was give you recommendations
on how to live and how to do politics
and the best way to run the the world
that's it you know she was not a
philosopher philosopher someone who
explains something if it's going to be
part of science and if you say well i'm
going to study at the university i'm
going to study philosophy
what are you going to study
recommendations is that what your
major is
oh i study recommendations i study on
how to do politics and how to do what to
believe in you know religion etc
opinions
is that what philosophy is just study of
nonsense of
opinions
so that's why we need to define the word
philosophy if you're going to go to
university and study philosophy
hopefully you're studying something that
is scientific meaning that you explain
something
how do we define certain knowledge here
this is how we end our
philosophy and uh knowledge segment
and for this you need to find out what
these people have been thinking about
all these hundreds of years thousands of
years
what what do you think knowledge is i
mean what is the purpose of now what are
you trying to achieve when you say you
know something how do you prove to
someone else that you know
something
and i gave the example the other day of
um do you know that napoleon went to
waterloo in 1815
do you know
that
napoleon even existed
prove it
prove it i want you to prove it
what are you gonna do
bring napoleon here
and even if you did i'm saying well
that's in 2022
it's not in 1815 when he went to
waterloo so that's not the same napoleon
i i mean i can raise a million arguments
against you you cannot prove
the existence of napoleon in 1815 much
less proved to me that napoleon went to
waterloo
there's no way to prove such a thing
and this goes to the moonies who believe
that you know
uh uh neil armstrong did not land on the
moon you know in 1969 i cannot prove it
to you i cannot bring you
know uh neil armstrong in 1969 today the
real thing i can give you a picture a
movie you know but not the real thing i
cannot reproduce it and say look here it
is because even then you would say well
that's not he did so today but not in
1969 so even that would fail
there's no way to prove it okay so how
do you prove knowledge how do you show
now that what do we mean by knowledge
and again i clarify that we don't use
words like time or knowledge in science
those words belong exclusively
to
religion okay we don't use the word time
or knowledge in science but we do define
these words
uh to show what the mathematicians and
the so-called philosophers meant by
these words for the last 3000 years okay
and so here it is here's uh the word
knowledge what we need to figure out
about it okay if you want to take it as
an action item if you want to define the
word knowledge here's a hint okay
so here we go
the best approach for arriving at a
definition of knowledge is to brainstorm
the properties we typically associate
with with this formidable word
now it seems to enjoy three essential
features to it
what you demonstrate to others
okay they
you take the test or you go in front of
a
three panel judge at the university and
say i'm gonna show you my knowledge i'm
gonna prove to you my now i want to show
you how much i know right
well you demonstrate it to someone else
that's how you
prove that you know you know you
regurgitate what you know okay
that's one issue then
in a single experiment
okay because
uh if i talk about you know napoleon
that's not knowledge that's just you
know i'm regurgitating something i
memorized is is that knowledge do you
know that napoleon existed do you know
that napoleon went to waterloo
no yes so you cannot do that but what i
can show you for example is an
experiment and do it in front of you and
say look i know what's going to happen
and here it is i let go of my pencil and
i say
i know
right i know
that it's going to fall to the floor
so i let go of it and fall to the floor
and i proved my knowledge right
so not only do i demonstrate my
knowledge but i'm also going to run an
experiment to show that i know
what's going to happen
okay
and in the future as opposed to the past
i cannot know the past because then i
cannot reproduce it and again this goes
to the moonies people who don't believe
we landed on the moon why because
there's no way i can show you anything
that happened before today
i can't prove to you i cannot
know it i cannot demonstrate it to you
because whatever happened the best i can
show you is a movie and even that you're
going to question say well that was done
in hollywood or whatever
so it's got to be the future knowledge
has to do only with the future you can't
know anything of the past you can only
know something of the future you know
like god the black universe the blocked
universe he knows what's going to happen
in the future because he's all-knowing
he's omniscient right so he knows
exactly what's going to happen in the
future
to you to anybody right supposedly right
so we have the three criteria there what
you demonstrate to others in a single
experiment and the future as opposed to
the past
okay the way you demonstrate knowledge
is to someone to someone is by
predicting
what is going to happen in a specific
experiment
and so here we have the definition okay
it was from why god doesn't exist my
book says knowledge the ability to
predict the outcome of a specific
experiment precisely
okay
ability to predict the outcome of a
specific experiment precisely that's
what knowledge has meant all these years
is there such a thing as knowledge
the answer is no there is no monster as
knowledge not even god has knowledge
he's not omniscient okay
um
why because very simple you know uh you
say well bill you let go of the pencil
and it fell to the floor and you
predicted you
can predict it
precisely
okay so i do the experiment and it falls
to the floor say do it again bill i
don't believe you okay so i do it again
you know repeatable experiment
and i keep doing that and i say okay see
i proved it to you i proved my knowledge
do it again bill okay so i said one more
time i let go of the pencil
and it stays up in the air
and you say
i i thought you predicted it was going
to fall it turns out that it did not
fall it stayed in the air
it turns out that you did not know that
i had two magnets and that that pencil
had you know a metal bar in it instead
of a lead uh
you know uh
piece
and so i held it up in the air with two
magnets which you did not know
you knew that horse is gonna win the
race
you knew for a fact because the others
were so rotten so bad
and you voted on on course number five i
voted on
horse number ten but he says there's no
way number 10 will win because it's the
worst horse in the lot and he's got a
crooked leg you know and there's no way
that horse is going to make it
what you did not know is that i had a
gun and i killed all the other horses
and the only one that crossed the finish
line was my horse
okay so uh you cannot predict the future
exactly because we do not know
everything and because we do not know
everything there is no such thing as
knowledge which is
to predict
the future uh the the the results of an
experiment
exactly without error that's what we
mean by the word knowledge there is no
such thing as knowledge
let's get down to the questions that we
had since i was oh no let me go with the
moonies here hold it we had some moonies
and so i'm gonna
cover them a little bit here
yeah here's the first one fo says
challenger accident with the names of
the twins yes twins just looked him up
he's saying that
uh some people survived
uh the challenger that they're still
around alive and i showed i think a
picture of that last time it looks like
this and they show some of these people
same names being older and they say hold
it these people exist still so that
challenger was a hoax by the government
you know and uh why do you believe this
is the question i've got you know why do
you believe this what you see there
uh i mean people
they they want to doubt the government
they said you know i've been burned by
the government so many times there's so
many conspiracies so many false flags
but then they believe this and they
don't question that they say oh look
yeah it's the same person
why do you believe that
where did you get that
i mean someone could be playing a hoax
on you maybe it's a cia for you the same
government
another foul says
uh says um
it mentions this uh astronaut ed ed
mitchell and he's the sixth astronaut to
walk on the moon as well believes that
e.t visited us there have been crashed
craft okay
there have been material and bodies
recovered and he was referring to to
roswell okay in new mexico where uh
there was uh some time back
a couple decades ago you know uh they
said they found an unidentified flying
object and then
they showed these pictures they have
them in a museum over there in roswell
where they see uh this e.t and uh
and uh people go and see this and they
go oh and uh and one of these is this
fellow ed mitchell the fact that he's an
astronaut doesn't mean that he knows
anything or that he
you know
can prove any of this oh he's got his
opinion and he's giving you his opinion
that you know the government is hiding a
lot of this stuff in secret places
and that the et's actually visited us
and there was a crash of a craft and
that's just his opinion and the
important thing is that nasa distanced
himself itself from uh ed mitchell and
said that that was his personal opinion
that they don't agree with what he's
saying
so
again you know the fact that someone
important you can have a president think
that
ets are for real
it's his opinion nothing but okay here
we hold another thing that you cannot
travel interstellarly it's impossible
for any living entity to travel to
another star okay just that simple
okay so
um uh and
you have to look through my site look
the pioneer
uh anomaly video and it'll explain why
we cannot travel to understand we never
will
i don't even think uh we're going to
colonize uh
uh you know some
object in the solar system like mars or
the moon i doubt that's gonna happen we
can probably somehow put a
you know some hut out there
with lights with all the
things there and live
a few astronauts maybe ten astronauts
can live in there
that might happen i doubt it very much
but we're not gonna we're not gonna
evacuate the earth we're not going to
colonize mars or the moon none of that
is ever going to happen so forget about
colonization
that part of the budget of nasa that
goes to that
if it develops some new technology more
power to them but to say that we're
actually going to colonize the moon and
mars and live there and so on absolute
nonsense it's never going to happen
okay
okay another rfl says neil armstrong
stepped on mars you can't prove that
neil armstrong did not step on mars this
is the line of argument you are using
um
what can i say okay again i can't
reproduce napoleon i cannot reproduce
neil armstrong stepping on the moon in
1969 again i cannot reproduce that
incident because even if i did you would
not believe it and say that was done in
hollywood et cetera et cetera so there's
no way to prove
anything from the past you cannot prove
history you cannot prove that caesar
existed or that he went to london you
know to england
so
you're looking for something that's
impossible you cannot prove the past uh
you can make an assumption
people say believe you don't really
believe you make an assumption you take
some things for granted we take for
granted that napoleon was a man that uh
lived
200 years ago and he did all this stuff
and why do we
accept that well because it was passed
on from generation to generation there's
no reason not to
accept it okay
but again you have to take that with a
grain of salt because
you might accept that that the napoleon
was there but do you accept that he
uh ate five times a day
someone might have theorized that and
say you know i think uh napoleon every
day for whatever reason he ate five
times a day
he can come up with anything and he said
do you believe that now
do you accept that you know and so it's
how much you want to accept from the
past now you can make an assumption you
know about the existence and what caesar
did you make that assumption based
on what you read what they passed what
our forefathers passed down to us
but you cannot reproduce caesar going to
england you cannot reproduce napoleon
going to waterloo you can't reproduce
that you just have to accept it on face
value and and that's it there's no more
than that and same with the moons
moon landings you know
okay uh here's another felon he says
it is it even possible to see an object
350 feet long from 258 miles away okay
he's talking about the iss the
international space station um can you
get your binoculars can you get your
telescope and see it out there when it
goes around the earth remember
nasa
has the schedule for when it goes
through what countries you know up there
and
this thing passes 15 times a day
about an hour every hour and a half
through
the same regions okay so it goes around
you know quite fast and the question is
can you see it he said
uh does the human eye even have the
resolution resolve
resolving power i doubt an aircraft
carrier could be seen from 100 miles
away
okay and so uh this is a shot of the
moon through a pair of binoculars
someone took
the moon is a little bigger obviously
than uh the iss
but it's a lot farther away
and yet we there's a shot through a pair
of binoculars this is more or less what
you would see
if you get your binoculars and focus it
on the moon you would see something
similar to that you see how is it
possible to see something so far away
well we've invented telescopes and
microscopes and
binoculars and so on
that's what we used to see far away and
what can i say uh just prove it to
yourself get a pair of binoculars
and see if you can see the iss don't
question whether you can see it try to
see it and then say yeah i can't see it
obviously you'd be answering your own
question there
so again i don't know some of these
people should should just do it
grab a pair by not just go out there
don't don't keep questioning can you see
it we'll do it and you'll find out if
you can't see it that way you don't
because if i say yes you can see it
you'll say well i don't believe you bill
i said what have we done we haven't
learned anything neither you nor i so
what you gotta do is do it yourself okay
this is something you can prove to
yourself that's why i say the iss is a
good way of handling the moon landings
not because you're going to believe in
the moon landings but because if you can
see the iss up there and you are
convinced and you finally
covered that base and say okay the iss
is out there it is rolling around the
earth it is a monster it's it's a device
it's not a hologram as one guy said
or some pair of lights or whatever no
you see it going around and you say okay
it's it's there i verified it for myself
and no one told me about it the cia is
not trying to do a false flag or trying
to convince me now i saw it with my own
eyes if you cover that base
then the next step is very simple how
did that thing get up there did they do
that in one shot or did they take
several rockets or did they take several
projects first before they could build
that thing up there
and that's when you start
pulling on the little string that takes
you to the center of the labyrinth okay
that's the way it works
okay uh someone says along the same line
even if you would see something resemble
the iss in the sky then you would need
to prove that it is a space station and
not something else
again uh
if you can't tell the difference between
you know uh an object up there
then maybe you just you have to get a
more powerful telescope microscope
binocular pair of lenses i don't know
whatever whatever you want to call it uh
detective uh eyeglass
you know you just get a powerful one and
convince yourself that that thing that's
out there is
you know a big um
field you know like a football field
size object
that's rolling around the earth and once
you convince yourself of that it's
you've got half the battle one ninety
percent of the battle one because now
you say okay uh they went through all
these steps to get that thing up there
that means they did run all these
experiments these projects where they
sent things into space among them
gagarin and tereshkova
and all these other things that they
sent up there and yeah why not uh
rockets to the moon
with or without people
i mean
why don't you think that we could send a
rocket to the moon
you don't think that's possible
and yeah i mean what can i say i mean if
you're a flat earther i can see why you
would not want to believe that because
you say well if we can send something
out there we could have taken a picture
of the earth and we know it's round and
that would destroy their theory so they
go with
second best they say we never sent
anything out there okay so i can
understand why they have a
a reason not to believe
what is you if you're an intelligent
person you know and you believe that the
moon landings
did not happen simply because you've
been pulled so much by the government
and by conspiracies and so on well just
verify what you can verify which is the
iss
okay
okay now yeah let's go uh with some of
the questions here and let's go with a
couple of these
phil says does nothing exist
if yes then uh it isn't nothing
if no then how do you know that lack of
something is nothing
well the way we do all these things is
not verification not with proofs not
with an experiment what we do is define
in science we begin with definitions as
long as
you follow the definitions i promise not
to hurt you okay
okay so here it is in order to know
right
whether lack of something is nothing in
science we define the words that make or
break our argument see how easy it was
all these years all you have to do is
define
and so we define these words exist
physical presence meaning something plus
location yeah we got the something now
what is something that which has shape
and what is nothing that which doesn't
have shape
so now we have definitions right now
we're going to use these definitions and
you cannot deviate one yoda from these
definitions you cannot take a single
letter away from these definitions you
must follow them
you may not like them but you must
follow them if you don't like them you
have to come up with your own mouse trap
you got to say i got a better mousetrap
bill okay get inside the ring
fight for your definition otherwise
these stay and we're going to work with
these definitions and we're going to
apply them to your it to your question
does nothing exist well
pursuant to the definition of exists
that you see there
nothing can't and doesn't exist why
because nothing is a concept
only things
things are those that have shape nothing
doesn't have shape so it doesn't qualify
for existence because existence requires
us something which is that which has
shape which nothing doesn't have
okay and then the issue has nothing to
do with knowledge so don't tell me how
you know
because uh existence is not a question
of knowledge
there is no provision
in the definition of existence or
knowledge but you try to figure it out
so something plus location
where's knowledge
there's no room for knowledge in there
okay so that's how we do it in science
we just work off of definitions so that
we know what we're saying okay we
understand what we're saying
okay one more interesting subject here
coming up phil says your definition
framework definitional framework for the
foundation of physics
you want to exclude physical law
experiment and measurement
in that framework how do you describe
define right your claim that water forms
globular
shapes in space
okay more or less along the uh uh
line of reasoning of flat earthers first
try to prove
okay that a space vacuum can even exist
we just proved that it can't exist
because vacuum space are synonyms by the
way vacuum space and nothing all three
are synonyms and they're concepts
because an object is that which has
shape so we don't have to worry about
existence there okay and so no space
vacuum nothing do not exist because
concepts do not exist only objects may
be said to exist
and nothing is that which doesn't have
shape which is what an object is that
which has shaped
okay how can we have a pressurized
system next to a space vacuum without
some sort of container so let's get the
first issues here uh
the fact that he says physical law
experiment and measurement okay let's
address those first because this poor
fellow is so lost he doesn't even know
who he is who his mother is so no such
monster is physical law not in science
science we don't deal with laws
and uh there's no such thing as a
physical law the word law was introduced
by the mathematicians in science we say
science is about rational explanation
and science is not about experiments or
about measurements okay we don't deal
with experiments or measurements those
are
those belong exclusively to mathematical
physics so here we have in this site you
know we do something different than
mathematical physics in science we don't
prove and science ex concepts do not
exist space is nothing which is a
concept therefore it's irrational to say
that nothing exists okay so i hope we
covered that base
uh what do we propose instead well we
propose something different to answer
his last issue there how can we have a
pressurized system next to a space
vacuum without some sort of a container
this is the issue that has the flat
earthers up at night okay they can't
sleep because of this
so let's begin slowly let's see if we
can uh
take them by the hand step by step where
their reasoning fails okay flat earthers
and then all the people who say
how can you curve water essentially
right that's the issue
okay well it start slowly okay we'll go
slowly and here it is
mathematical physics proposes
discrete particles there's no relation
between any particles there's space to
say that
exists
between particles in other words
particles are not touching each other
they're all separated okay this is what
mathematical physics has this is what we
had for the last 3000 years that's why
they cannot explain gravity they cannot
explain
magnetism they cannot explain light or
the workings of the atom because they
work with discrete particles anyone
working with particles should be kicked
out of science because if in 3 000 years
you haven't figured out that you cannot
do physics the invisible stuff
intangible stuff that mother nature does
every day like gravity and magnetism
if if you haven't realized in 3000 years
that you can't do it with discrete
particles then you got a mental problem
okay so that's the way we look at it
uh what do we propose instead we propose
that all atoms in the universe are
physically interconnected
physically
interconnected something is connecting
every atom in the universe i hope you
see the difference right now i'm just
telling you what we propose here so that
you can understand the answer
uh to the question that was asked okay
which is how do you curve water that's
what we're getting to okay so first we
have to separate mathematical physics
discrete particles from the rope model
which is all atoms are physically
interconnected okay that's where we
start we don't ask that you believe we
ask that you take this as an assumption
we're gonna make this assumption okay
hopefully uh we've got this
uh
under under our skin now okay
okay so let's remove this give me a
second here
okay so we're saying that all atoms are
physically interconnected we got that so
far i i hope i didn't lose any
person out there this kindergarten stuff
okay
okay so uh
what do we propose we propose that why
does the earth
go around the sun again we're proposing
this here doesn't mean you have to
believe us okay we're saying what are we
proposing we're saying why does the
earth go around the sun well you just
saw that all atoms are physically
interconnected that means that every
atom of the earth including every atom
of you is connected to every atom of the
sun which is connected to every atom of
the moon
every atom in your body is connected to
every atom of my body right through the
earth
that's the proposal that's the
assumption
okay understand the assumption we're not
asking you to believe
we're asking you to make believe right
that it is true that that's what's out
there that all atoms are physically
interconnected okay that's where we
start
so how do we explain the orbit of the
earth around the sun according to this
model and let's get all this right
we're saying that if every atom is
interconnected the sun twirls the earth
around itself and the earth turns the
moon around itself okay
and here you see the earth orbit okay
because every atom of the earth is bound
to every atom of the sun
uh what is space nothing there's no
friction with nothing because nothing is
that which has no shape there is no
thing called space so there is no
friction and therefore the earth can
roll around forever because the sun is
twirling in by the
uh
electromagnetic ropes which is what
we're saying interconnects any two atoms
so all atoms of the earth are connected
to every single atom of the sun the sun
twirls the earth around through these
mediators that we cannot see or touch
okay
and that's why the earth rolls around
the sun and doesn't lose speed because
it doesn't
have any friction with space
the earth does the same thing to the
moon okay so the every atom of the moon
is bound to every atom of the earth
including you so every atom of your body
is bound to every atom of the moon
that's why you can see the moon because
light propagates along that mediator all
the way to your eye otherwise you would
not see the moon
the reason you see the moon you see it
through the electromagnetic roads that
interconnect every atom of the moon to
every atom in your eye
okay
we got it so far do you believe in it we
don't care
we don't care if you believe we're
asking you to make the make believe you
you have to
you have to concede the assumption
to understand the theory founded upon
that assumption
okay do we have that straight okay so
we're going to make an assumption that
all atoms in the universe are physically
interconnected we're saying that every
atom of the earth is bound to every atom
of the sun the sun twirls the earth
around more or less like i'm gonna twirl
this ball
there is a physical connection i only
have one here okay i can't make the
gazillions of atoms are bound from the
ball to my finger but this is what
happens this is how the sun throws the
earth around and we do the same thing to
the moon
that's the mechanism we're proposing
we're saying that the reason people miss
this throughout all these years is that
they thought an object that a thing
an entity was that which you can see or
touch
and that's where the irrational
irrationality started we're saying that
and
a thing
is not that which you can see or touch
it's that which has shape
and not all objects we can see or touch
among them the air hopefully the air is
something and we cannot see the air we
can touch it but we can't see it and
there are other things that we cannot
even see or touch okay but anyways um
so now we get to this issue so far i
hope you understood that much okay now
we get to the issue of water curving
around the earth
okay so we're gonna show illustrate show
you a little video a little quick video
of why what causes the mechanism
of how water not only water but air as
well curves around the
round the spherical more or less
spherical earth okay that's what we're
going to show now we're going to show
you a movie
so
we can keep our mouth shut if we wanted
to but we're going to give you a little
explanation in the background so that
you know what you're staring at okay but
i think it'll be self-evident once you
see it okay here it goes okay very
slowly for all of you okay let me put it
over here
okay
here you have the earth
and the dark blue is the ocean the
oceans
we divided them into oceans but they're
all really connected it's like we have a
single ocean on earth no problem either
way that you want to see it the dark
blue are the oceans and you can see uh
it's a 2d
version but uh you have to imagine that
as a globe
as a spherical
type of object the earth okay and the
water is curved around that earth that's
what we're proposing okay why because
every atom of the water every atom that
forms
the ocean every single atom is bound to
every other atom
of the earth including two
parts of the ocean that are on the other
side of the planet
okay
so we have this atom is connected to the
one on the other side of the atom and
the other atom here is connected to the
other side to an atom on the other side
of the atom
of the uh of the earth okay and if you
put all these together well you end up
with a sphere
okay that's what you end up with what
because they're all tending towards the
center that's what gravity is
uh
and mass what it is is essentially
everything tending towards the center
everything's being drawn towards the
center and that creates a spherical
object and that's why almost every
object in the universe is spherical
why are they spherical well in the earth
we say here was a star used to be a sun
it was a star
that's how you can create a spherical
object such as the earth okay
because every star because of its great
gravity because everything's tending
towards the center of that object
forms a spherical surface
that eventually compresses little by
little by little by little
okay and eventually creates the elements
by fusing them together so you have the
heavier elements you take hydrogen and
helium and you compress them all the way
to iron and higher elements that's what
we're doing that's what the earth is
earth is made that way that's why we're
saying the earth used to be a sun used
to be a star that was compressed
into this cinder
known as a black dwarf that's what the
earth is
and then as you can see not only do the
elements go from heavier in the center
of the earth to lighter on the outside
all the way to gases which is what the
air is that's covering our planet gases
such as nitrogen and
oxygen and so on okay but what's the
issue now you have the air why does the
air stay i mean there's no container
there's nothing on the outside over here
nothing on the outside of water
except space which we said is nothing
it's not a container because it's not a
thing it doesn't have shea so why does
all this stay
and curve around the spherical earth
well again there we see
little atom that i'm showing little red
one there here is over there
now you see down the bottom
on the other side sorry and now you'll
see it on the bottom
okay where are they being tugged towards
well they're all tugged eventually
towards the center of the earth
that's why the air does not leave our
planet that's why the further the air is
the lighter it is there's fewer and
fewer atoms further out
and uh the farther away it is the less
pull it has towards the center of the
earth and at some point there is no air
you get into absolute space where maybe
you find an atom here and there maybe
you know but the issue is that explains
why the earth is spherical why water
curves around the earth why air curves
around the spherical earth because all
atoms are physically interconnected
do you believe it we don't care do you
accept it we don't care we explain to
you so that you understand the mechanism
okay
and and the cause and once you
understand that you reach your own
conclusion whether you believe it or not
it's your personal
uh opinion and uh good luck with that
you know we don't care that's religion
we're talking about physics we're trying
to explain
cause mechanism and we explained it
there we're saying all atoms are
physically interconnected that leads to
spherical objects celestial objects and
which leads in the case of the earth and
some other planets with a
gaseous surface that is also connected
to a more solid usually
interior of that object okay
but here let me show you another one
because you say okay that's gravity
what if i have just a drop of light you
know here these people have this notion
that uh
you know
that uh weather is only level let's see
if i can level uh like that you know
it's level why because what happens is
that here we're relying on gravity and
uh if it weren't for the glass this
thing would have a level surface it
would not be flat you know
and so they say well this is my
experience this is the experience these
people have the flat earthers and so
they say you know show me
that you can curve that
well yeah you won't do it with your ruby
rubber ducky
in your bathtub okay you won't see live
light
uh water curving in your bathtub because
you don't have the mass in the water to
do what i just showed you with the earth
the oceans of the earth and the gases
air you know that cover the earth okay
but let me show you something that you
can visualize okay
we're talking about visualization so
that you understand that's what we're
talking about here we're not asking you
to believe we're asking you to
understand you reach your own conclusion
okay so here it goes very
easy
we have an astronaut and he releases
water into space okay maybe a bucket of
water so he just throws the water out
there without the baby okay so he throws
water out there he throws a blob of
water
it is in no container whatsoever okay
all we have is a blob of water there's
no container because space is not a
container space is nothing that which
has no shape so it doesn't qualify as a
container he's going to release a
a bundle of water
okay and here it is okay
and
does that thing have shape does that
water have shape that drop of water
it could be a drop of water it could be
a bucket of water it's water or some
kind of liquid we don't care the point
here is does that thing have shape
and you say we don't know okay so let's
stop it okay there it is
okay
what you're staring at we took a
snapshot of that
does that have shape
does it have a container
and yeah it has shape but it has no
container and it's a liquid some kind of
liquid okay
and so the issue here is yes you can
have shape of water without a container
you do not need a container
to uh curve water and you can see the
water is kind of curved there isn't it
okay and we did it without um
without putting it in that container
okay so
we're just trying to make you understand
we're not trying to convince you or for
you to believe you believe whatever you
want all i'm saying is we have
mechanisms
and the mechanism is the first one is
that all atoms are physically
interconnected that pulls everything
towards the center that explains why all
celestial objects are
spherical
you know not perfectly spherical but
they are
steroids and whatever you know spherical
like
and it also explains why water and
liquids and gases also curve around
those objects you know you have jupiter
it's just a bunch of gases
you have
mars for those of you who believe this
you know
mars is a planet that has co2 so it is
venus that has co2 around it you say why
doesn't that co2 fly away it's a gas
isn't it and gases tend to expand
well not there not out there because the
gravity in other words the ropes to
which each atom is attached does not
allow it to leave the planet that's why
gases form an envelope around these
planets
okay now we do have a true genuine flat
earther and he's the guy who went out
there and actually looked at this so he
has a question okay so finally i had
someone who actually goes out there
and
uh tries to understand what i'm saying
when i'm saying you know that uh water
and air can curve around the earth okay
so here's this question says where's the
mechanism for the observation of gravity
how does this mechanism work okay
how is it able to hold massive standing
bodies of water onto a globe so that the
water is not level but instead returned
in other words he's referring again to
this this is his experience that you
know
water just falls because of gravity
right
and and leaves a flat surface okay so
this is his experience he hasn't
uh evolved beyond this this is the issue
so this is what he bases his experience
uh
on and this is the only thing he
regurgitates okay
reality demonstrates the physics of
water okay again he's talking about this
case only that alone is enough to know
it's not a globe okay would love to get
a response on this okay and show some
real world physics
of standing bodies of water with a
curved surface
so i showed them the same thing that i
showed just showed
for this other fellow here it is okay
that every atom is connected physically
connected to every atom on earth so it's
pulled in that direction okay so
everything
pulls towards the center of the earth
and that explains why water curves
around the round this earth
and air you know encapsulates the
spherical earth
what does this foul say okay he follows
up and he says finally he understood
imaginary fantasy mathematical ropes i
don't know where he got the mathematical
part because this has nothing to do with
mathematics they said where are these
ropes bill yeah that's that's now that
he understood it now he's gonna question
where the ropes are but at least i think
he understood the mechanism i think he
did you know i can't say for sure okay
but he apparently uh
now at least understands the mechanism
now he's questioning
whether they exist
where are they why can't i see
or touch
these ropes that's what he's talking
about see all these people are looking
for an experiment they want you to prove
through some kind of evidence
meaning experiment meaning c touch right
that the ropes are binding any two atoms
now we can't see an atom one atom
you can't see any atom not even the
uranium atom you cannot see it you would
have to go to a microscope or even a
high powered microscope site such as a
sem or atomic force microscope then you
might see
uh not the individual atom with the a
little electron rolling around that you
won't see what you'll see is a bird's
eye view of something which is roundish
which again shows that an atom is really
more like what we say a membrane that
encapsulates a proton star and not what
quantum mechanics says which is a little
bead that's rolling around because
that's not what we see we do not see a
little bead rolling around when we look
through the sam and i i did work with
sam's by the way and
or an atomic force microscope that's not
what you would see you do not see a
little ball rolling around what you see
is a membrane
okay you see
a ball
okay so we're saying that all atoms are
interconnected you can't see an atom but
he wants to see the ropes
that interconnect two atoms which we
can't see
he wants to be able to touch them
and so he says where are these robes
and again these people are looking for
proof
we're not here for proof first of all
you cannot prove anything that's
invisible intangible
we cannot prove anything that's
invisible intangible i cannot
bring it to you and show it to you
because it's invisible intangible okay
so what do we do
well we do the spoon experiment to show
why their logic fails okay
i let go of a spoon okay here we have a
spoon a little spoon okay
i let go of a spoon
and we all know
we don't believe we know right that it's
got to fall downwards to the floor okay
we do this experiment every day real
world physics real world fizzy you let
go of the spoon it falls to the floor
okay we know this we have the experience
with it
now here's the million dollar question
please listen carefully
can you see or touch anything above or
below the spoon other than the air
is there something else here that you
can see or touch other than the air and
of course if you went out into space and
there's no
no
atoms out there you're completely
between two galaxies you know completely
in the middle of a space nothing there
and you do the experiment again you
won't find anything above or below
there's not even going to be any air in
here okay
so the question is here you have a spoon
you let go of it it falls to the floor
there's nothing above it nothing below
it
is there nothing here is there something
here or nothing here
if you say there isn't
because you can't see
or touch it because it's invisible
intangible you are going to do this
experiment you're going to explain this
experiment with black magic you're
invoking black magic you can't use a
concept such as density you can't use
the word gravity
whatever word you use it better not be a
concept you need a physical object to
say that this came down
it's like saying you pulled on the horse
and the horse came towards you
but you use no rope you use no elongated
objects such as a rope or
or a wire or a cable or anything like
that you just went like this and the
horse came towards you
so how do you explain that well if you
explain it without an elegated object
between your hands and the horse you're
using black magic you did it by magic
you have no explanation for how that
horse came towards you and the same
thing here if i let go of the spoon and
you're saying there's nothing here above
or below it no particles pushing no
ropes pulling
then you're doing black magic you're
saying that this fell down because of
black magic same thing here
and when you say this is level why what
if and i'm sure that if i break the
glass or or turn it upside down that
water is going to fall to the floor
that's our experience why does that
water fall to the floor what's pulling
on it what's pushing on it
please identify the invisible intangible
object that is pulling or pushing on the
water and if you say there's no object
because i cannot see or touch it you're
going to do your explanation with black
magic
so you have a choice you either go with
the ropes or you go with black magic if
you have a third option
could be particles whatever but if you
have another option please let me know
okay
let me know uh how you're going to
explain
why that water is level and don't use
any concept we need physical objects we
need an object that we can that you can
illustrate so you need to do a lot of
pictures okay
and so here this is how we explain why
what causes the spoon to fall to the
floor here it is
okay
all atoms of the spoon are connected to
every atom in on earth
every atom of the floor every atom all
the way to the center of the earth and
to the other side so i i haven't drawn
the gazillions of ropes that connect
every atom of the spoon to every atom on
earth you have to imagine that what
we're saying is the reason the spoon
falls is the
ropes that connect every atom are uh
fanning out they go they open up right
and you have more and more individual
ropes that are not aligned that are
essentially
causing this acceleration to happen
that's our explanation you don't have to
believe it we don't care if you believe
it or not we're giving you an
explanation of why the spoon what causes
the spoon to fall to the floor
if you say there's nothing there between
the spoon and the floor you are doing it
with black magic
okay so your job is to explain gravity
why what causes the spoon to fall to the
floor hopefully you're using objects
you're using things you're not using
abstract concepts such as mass force
field
wave any of those you can't use concepts
you have to use a physical object
physical object that would just shape
okay you don't like my definition bring
a better mousetrap defend your
definition first before you even begin
to talk
okay another follow says uh
uh
he puts these words uh that i'm saying
this okay and he's right this is what
i'm saying that math geometry doesn't
belong in science physics when it's a
primary tool in these fields
no science is rational explanations we
do not use math geometry at all we have
no use for math or geometry because math
own and geometry meaning you know
essentially the relations that we see in
geometric figures
those are just concepts and they only
describe and science we explain
physics rational explanations of
phenomena of mechanism philosophy of
purposes and reasons and if you don't
like my definitions you cannot use the
fallacy of authority democracy or
tradition
okay
now the fellow says
uh give me a second here
oh god here
okay another fellow says this he accuses
me of saying i think it's the same file
he says
believe that only objects or concepts
that there are only objects or concepts
when space motion collisions are neither
well you have to define the word concept
in order to say that see you can't just
say that uh
motion collisions space are neither
concepts or objects we we don't know
what you're talking about until you
define the word concept we won't know
okay
and um yeah
and then you gotta show why space
uh motion and collision are not concepts
and what are they instead what's the
what category do they fall under okay of
types of words there's only two
categories according to this side and
that's concepts and objects every word
in the dictionary can be be divided
between those two one is that which has
shape the other one that which doesn't
have shape essentially okay that's the
concept
and so you either are a concept or
you're an object
and again a word that invokes or
embodies two objects or two words treat
it as objects that's what a concept is
okay so we do have a definition we work
off of definitions you don't like it
come up with a better definition don't
use the one in the dictionary for sure
it's wrong it's irrational okay okay if
it says a circle is an object yes
that which has shape yes that's what an
object is
it exists because it has physical
presence object plus location no a
circle does not have location
uh the paper maybe the ink
the chalk the board those have location
not the circle
okay so no uh you failed on that last
one
two out of three ain't so bad anyways
okay
so um
fella says
in regards to your electromagnetic
threat single thread right how can a
single indivisible entity bend
isn't the state of something bending
doesn't it imply a relationship of
multiple entities
in other words he's saying that
uh
if it's a single thread made of a single
piece
how does it bend
because we associate
bending with lots with many
constituents many parts
and then you can imagine something
bending but if it's made of a single
piece you would think it's rigid that's
what he's saying here okay so he wants
to understand that okay
and what we do in science is we make
assumptions and these are the
assumptions we make for the thread
okay
people say i don't believe you i don't
accept these that's fine yeah you accept
whatever you want we make these
assumptions in order to explain how our
universe works okay so these are the
assumptions we make for the thread okay
here it goes
single thread okay there's only one
thread in the entire universe converts
into all these atoms and the ropes that
interconnect them there's a single
closed loop thread floating in space if
you can say in space meaning it's just
floating in nothingness okay within
nothingness whatever you want to use as
words it's made of a single piece
okay
uh it's unbreakable you cannot break it
okay you cannot tear it you cannot cut
it okay so it's made of a single piece
okay
it's like um wonder woman's uh lasso
okay rope okay so it's made of a single
piece it doesn't break okay there's a
single thread makes up all the matter in
the universe
it's flexible
which is his problem with with the
assumptions okay
it's invisible you can't see it
it's intangible doesn't understand what
visibility and intangibility is those
are things of our macro world those are
phenomena of our macro world okay
uh the thread is flexible but it's made
of a single piece that's where he's got
in his mind a contradiction okay and it
also goes through itself even though you
can't cut it it doesn't cut
itself okay so we have these assumptions
you say man those are all magical
assumptions bill
yeah in our everyday
macro world these are irrational
assumptions these are extraordinary
assumptions
first thing you have to understand is
that when you're going to deal with
gravity when you're going to be dealing
with light
with the workings of the atoms with uh
magnetism right
you're dealing with something
extraordinary that we don't have in our
everyday
world
why because here you see again to my two
magnets okay two little magnets
and they attract each other and there's
nothing in between
and there's nothing pushing from the
outside because you can feel the pull
from the inside okay so there one's
pulling on the other
you can do the experiment on your own at
home but you'll feel that there's
already a tug from the inside it's not
from the outside but there's nothing in
between here nothing you can see or
touch
so is there nothing between these two
magnets
if you say nothing you're doing black
magic
and if you say something is there like
mister
what's that maxwell said
and like mr faraday said there is
something there some exotic type of
matter then hopefully it's invisible and
intangible
okay
so you can't see it you can't touch it
there's something there it's invisible
and intangible that's the first
conclusion that's a rational conclusion
so if if i can bring something to you
and say this is what's in there and i
show it to you and you can touch it
i'm not representing the actual world of
mother nature because mother nature's
world is that it's invisible and
intangible meaning i cannot bring it to
you and show it to you other than as a
concept in this case the rope
okay i can say this is what it looks
like in that world that we can't see or
touch
okay this is
the architecture that that thing has
because the thing is that which has
shape not that which you can see your
touch
and then
you're saying well how can it be made of
a single piece and flexible
again you're deriving this from your
experience of everyday stuff and it
turns out that we see examples of this
in our everyday world you know
you take a solid you take a steel beam
and you can't run it through another
steel beam they kind of
clash they hit each other and push each
other away
you can't get them to melt into another
unless you change the again you know
heat it up melt it then maybe you could
do it but steel beam you know we usually
can't pass them through each other and
here i'll do it with now a steel beam
with something a little less heavy two
pencils
and they don't seem to go through each
other
if it's solid it's very hard to get
something to go through each other
okay but now try it with water
you know in fact here's you have water
okay
and you can see this which is
solid right it goes right through the
water
okay you can see how it goes let's see
maybe there
so it goes right through the water
and you say how
how did that happen how did i get
something solid to go through
a liquid in fact
this already went through the air
through the gas
it's going right through it
he said hold it how can
some atoms go through some other atoms
it's unheard of right and we see it
every day
every day we see pencils going through
the air right
or through liquids
and so
so this notion that you have that
this uh that something which is made of
a single piece
uh is also flexible or goes through each
other
well
you have to understand that these are
properties
that we inherited from the thread the
thread has these properties and we have
these properties in our everyday world
that we take for granted we say well we
know a solid doesn't go through a solid
but a solid goes through a gas and goes
through liquid and we don't have a
problem with that
where did we get these properties
well maybe we got them from the thread
maybe the thread
this uh single thread that makes up
every bit of matter in the universe has
some of these properties and that's why
the atoms depending on how they're
arranged
and how much heat there is how much cold
there is well then they have these
properties where do they inherit these
properties from the mother from the
single thread so i don't think these um
properties these attributes these
assumptions
are off the wall we have to explain the
real world out there the real world is
that we cannot see the mediators of
gravity and magnetism we cannot
smell them we cannot touch them okay
so there is something there but we
cannot see or touch it meaning that's
not the definition of an object the
definition of an object is that which
has shape we're saying it has the shape
of a rope that interconnects two atoms
and why do we say that because with that
assumption we can explain light and
gravity
that's why we make that assumption it's
a very useful handy assumption to
explain light and gravity and so
it's something we can't prove to you we
can't bring the actual rope
that mother nature has out there we can
only say look this is what we think is
out there and so that you can understand
the mechanism what properties does it
have well it has all these properties
that you see in our everyday world which
is solid can't go through solid but
solid can go through gas and water and
liquid
okay so this is the way you have to look
at it anyways
with that i'll see you next sunday and
hopefully we'll continue with some of
these subjects we'll see that